من اصل 274 الف مشاركه من طلاب وطالبات في
السعوديه
ترشح هؤلاء للمرحله الاخيره في مسابقه
المهارات الثقافيه
يعزفون ويكتبون ويمثلون ومع اهلهم يحتفلون
في بدايه مسيرتي ادباء وفنانين واعيدين
[موسيقى]
كيف قدرت تفوز اليوم
مع التعب وكل يوم كيف اتدرب ودائما اكون
انا واثق في نفسي واكون اكون حتى لو انا
دحين ما كنت فيه دحين حتى لو ما جبته حكون
اجرب واتدرب واتدرب الين ما يجي السنه
الجايه واقدر العب وافوز ان شاء الله ايام
كثير يوسف كان يتعب تدريب كان يكون يبغى
يوقف بس عشان يوصلوا هنا لازم يكملوا
يؤمنوا بنفسهم قبل ما احنا حتى نؤمن بهم
طبعا
بالمدرسه التاثيريه والمدرسه التجريديه
اللي هم من اصعب المدارس في الفن واستخدمت
في اللوحه السكين وتعتبر من اصعب الاشياء
في الرسم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مسارات ثقافيه ابداعيه شملتها المسابقه
بجوائز تتخطى خمسه ملايين ريال بين زحمه
الاحتفالات اب يواسي ابنته شوفتكم طلوع
المسرح اكبر مكسب تمام وهي حاولت المحاوله
الاولى في محاوله ثانيه وان شاء الله تكسب
هذه تالا تتحمل حتجيبها ان شاء الله
والشكر لكم ما قصرتوا نحتفل انا وهي صليت
شوف كيف استلهم الطلاب في مسار الادب قصصا
مختلفه اثرت فيهم احداهن اختارت المخدرات
واخر وثق اصوات العالقين تحت انقاذ زلزال
تركيا وسوريا لما اشوفوا ارقام الناس
الناس تتحول لارقام هذا الشيء يعني يؤلم
فانا كنت احاول اعيش في مكانهم واحاول
اوصل شعورهم في اخر لحظات اقرا كل يوم
تقريبا الى كتابين الى ثلاثه كتب او
روايات فلذلك كانت الكتابه القراءه شيء
جميل بالنسبه لي واكتب كل يوم الى قصه او
قصتان في اليوم فلذلك كانت الكتابه
بالنسبه لي شيء سهل لاني اكتبه منذ نعومه
اظافرين المسابقه تاتي بشراكه بين وزارتي
التعليم والثقافه التي كرمت اهالي الطلبه
بمبالغ ماليه وصلت لخمسين الف ريال لكل
اسره ومشاركه من فنانين وكتاب في التكريم
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه جده
[موسيقى]